Matthew seems to be the guy who you can
trust when if you're reading a script
you can turn to him because he's an
actor do you think you could only be in
love with someone in the business I mean
I know the guys you've dated we've
talked about in the past Robert Downey
Jr Nicholas Cage
um if Matthew's listening I'm sorry I'm
bringing all this up John F Kennedy John
F Kennedy Jr which I don't I would never
want to follow that guy I mean Matthew
must be a very secure man when did you
know you were in love I knew pretty
quickly I was going to movies one night
with my brother
and I showed up at the Film Forum and my
brother was meeting Matthew's best
friend
um and so then Matthew was there and
then that movie was sold out so we
walked up to 8th Street and then we were
gonna see um fisher king do you remember
Robin Williams Robin Williams and um the
movie wasn't starting yet so we went
across the street and got some pizza but
we had been told by a filmmaker that I
had just finished working with Andy
Bergman who wrote and directed honeymoon
in Vegas he wrote and directed The
Freshman in Blazing Saddles and the
in-laws and things like that or wrote
those movies um directed our movies told
he's incredible and he had told Matthew
you know I'm working with Sarah Jessica
you should meet her and he told me you
should meet Matthew and so we met and
we're like oh Andy Bergman and then we
were both seeing other people so it was
illegal and we stayed away from one
another and then you wanted Matthew but
you were being loyal to the person you
were seeing we understood that we had to
do right by the other people and break
up officially like we couldn't be
oh my God around so we had our first
official date on March 8th of 1992 and
we've been together ever since and um
but what does that mean been together
ever since did you move in together
right away was it that intense we've
we've never spent a night apart since
then with the exception of work on
location or his mother was ill for a bit
um so he went to take care of her but
from that first night we've never been
apart and wow so then pretty soon into
our relationship I I felt like
yeah like I'm I I'm in love with him and
he's incredible exactly what is love to
you well I think first of all I just
admired I admired him I loved his work I
had seen all of his movies I had paid to
go see them I'd been on location
shooting movies and gone to see them and
um I could remember every place I'd seen
him but I didn't realize that I was a
fan you know I just thought I'd like his
work but I liked his person very much
he's so smart he's so funny I like his
choice of friends the way he was living
in New York what was important to him
how he kind of traveled around the city
you know he's always traveling on on
this bicycle he's been riding bike since
he was 14 he was on a messenger bike you
know with no brakes and holding onto
buses and
um really smart and really talented and
he was I thought so beautiful and
handsome and Charming
and our lives we had been brought up in
similar ways our lives were very
different but things in our house were
very much the same the things that had
been influencing my parents very much
his parents they were different and but
there were touchstones in our home that
were identical which was probably the
case with a lot of people from our
generation who might be City kids you
know or yeah Pete Seeger was playing or
this or that or you know a bunch of
stuff
um
yeah and I just you know I love being
home in New York I loved I wanted to
build a life here and he was born and
raised in the West Village literally
he's never lived north of 11th Street
you guys sound like you have an
unbelievable marriage I know so many
actresses who said to me I will never
marry a guy who's an actor I will never
marry an actor it's just they they
[__] get competitive and they can't
be happy for you when you have a success
yeah and it's jealousy and it's just too
much
I know yeah I think
that's all possible and it doesn't mean
that I'm not of him sometimes and he's
not of me I don't know we you know we
haven't kept track of that or I haven't
felt it but yeah I'm sure that's all
possible but
um
but he's just happened to be the person
you know that's not I can do nothing
about it
foreign